often the hardest thing in science
fiction is coming up with a point of
view for the world that you're creating
we spend most of our time with our hero
tribe which is the alchemy Baba Voss is
the leader of the tribe he's got a
responsibility to protect their village
and his family the tribe is a mountain
tribe maybe 65 75 people somewhat
isolated from other tribes as the show
goes on you get to open up the world and
see a lot of different drives we have a
plastic tribe we have a metal tribe you
have the Rope tribe which is our alchemy
the world isn't just our small little
University we are creating an entire
world
something's different
it's children they have the ability now
confess it vision disappeared the 600
year even the concept of it would be
gone there would be no way of describing
what it is and so for the people who
don't have it when it returns it's
witchcraft and it's even bolivars tried
exists within a larger nation called the
fire nation and that is governed by a
queen queen Cain afraid that people with
vision might have a power over her and
so she sent a twitch finder out to look
for the children for centuries we feared
this day would come
the evil of light was almost destroyed
the world and now it has returned find
the children who can see in Frank's
country these two children their true
father kind of a mythical figure named
Geralyn morale
just total our gift they hope
acknowledge that will begin in the world
they're the first humans that have been
able to see in hundreds and hundreds of
years so together they have protected
children you see
[Music]
I have been looking for you my life
[Music]
you
[Music]